[Music]
there's no product or service
any company can build that assures
sustainable competitive advantage
companies that adapt to changing
conditions survive and thrive
the cycle of innovation is ever faster
can your company
learn and adapt fast enough hi
my name is dino kieza and i'm part of
the apogee team
at google application innovation is an
imperative
today i'll explain the central role apis
play
and how apogee edge lets you manage the
apis to power
innovation you're part of a modern
company
you're embracing cloud technologies more
and more you know that's required
you also know that to really deliver
business innovation
you've got to connect to partners better
and build ecosystems around your
offerings
and to do that you know you've got to
experiment you've got to adopt
agile business practices encourage and
cultivate fresh ideas
measure the right things reward progress
and you've got to act quickly
the key technology that enables all of
this is apis
api's power the modern applications that
deliver innovation
want voice ordering easy partner
integration
context across multi-channel
conversations
social login for users apis enable all
of those
apis are the mechanism for building
better experiences for your users
whether they're customers partners
vendors or employees
an agile business has got to exploit
apis to drive innovation
and managing those apis is an imperative
today i'm going to show you how apogee
edge works to enable
you to manage all the apis that power
application innovation for your business
first let's take a quick look at what
you get with apogee edge
there are three basic categories of
capability in the api management
platform
support for your developer ecosystems to
let people discover
and understand your apis and rapidly
build applications that use them
second monitoring and analytics so that
your api program managers
can see which apis are being used and
how
or so that they can get alerted when
appropriate and third
an api run time so you can expose usable
friendly
efficient apis that are secure
in upcoming videos i'll walk you through
detailed demonstrations of these three
key capabilities
in the apigee api management platform
[Music]